hey 42 here we've only been able to
record sound for just over 150 years but
in that time we have done some amazing
things with sound and captured some
amazing historical events here's a
rundown of some of the creepiest and
most chilling sounds ever recorded sound
recording was invented in 1857 by
édouard leon scott de martinville when
he created the fond autograph it was
used to create the first ever sound
recording which is believed to be the
inventor himself singing oh clair de la
lune in 1860
by today's audio standards it's a very
creepy sounding recording and being over
a hundred and fifty four years old is an
imperative piece of history in the early
1960s a space race was on
between the United States and the Soviet
Union the competition between the two
nations was fierce and whoever
successfully made it into space first
would forever have bragging rights the
American tragedies that ensued as a
result of their attempts to reach space
are well known but the Soviet Union's
not so much at that time many amateur
radio enthusiasts were building homebrew
radio equipment at their homes that
allowed them to listen in to space
communication frequencies used by the
two nations during their voyages to
brothers in Turin Italy named aquila and
Giovanni Dudek accordingly were way
ahead of most people in this field with
their radio and telecommunications
equipment they were able to tune into
all the Soviet Union's space frequencies
and record their transmissions in May of
1961 the two brothers picked up a
transmission from a Soviet space
frequency that chilled them to the very
core it was the voice of a female
clearly in distress this is a short clip
of the actual recording made by the
brothers
the woman is speaking in Russian but
when translated she is saying I feel hot
I can see a flame am I going to crash
yes yes I will re-enter and then the
transmission cuts out three days after
the recording was made the official
Soviet news agency Tass announced a
failed reentry of a satellites the size
of a boss
however the launch had not been
previously announced and the satellite
was never mentioned to anyone to this
day the soviet union has never
acknowledged the alleged incident and
the identity of the woman still remains
completely unknown at number three is a
1922 recording made by Thomas Edison of
Harry even three Edison recorded it on
his own invention the phonograph which
was the very first audio player the idea
was to sell them according to owners of
Edison's phonograph so that they could
play it to their children and experience
Christmas joy
but it had the opposite effects in fact
it's just about the most terrifying
Christmas message you will ever hear
here's a short clip from the original
recording but most of you know that
cannot be true for every Christmas you
see what I
and now you not only know just what I do
but you hear my old voices I'm speaking
who knows all the doors and I languish
I'm Santa Claus
The Laugh alone is enough to put kids up
Farva Christmas forever
Saturn is a source of intense radio
emissions in 2002 when the Cassini
spacecraft did a flyby of Saturn it
recorded these strange radio emissions
emanating from Saturn if you listen
closely you can hear what appears to be
an alien voice it's very hard to make
out any words yet some people believe
they have deciphered the message as of
this you people are urged to drop the
earthly impulse what do you think is it
aliens or just gargled space static
operation wandering soul was an attempt
by the US military during the Vietnamese
war to scare the opposition to
submission by playing terrifying sounds
for the jungle in the dead of night
it is the vain Moniz believed that the
dead must be buried in their homeland or
their soul will wander aimlessly in pain
and suffering therefore when they heard
the following sound echoing out the
depths of the dense jungle they would
have certainly felt a great sense of
turmoil and dread
the US militants would often broadcast a
sound from loudspeaker systems abroad
helicopters during the Cold War for over
30 years the shortwave radio spectrum is
used by the world's intelligence
agencies to transmit secret messages to
their spies who were stationed in enemy
countries these transmissions were
called number stations and were
completely anonymous one-way radio
transmissions across shortwave radio
that could be picked up and listened to
by anyone using only very basic radio
equipment number stations were broadcast
24 hours a day on very rigid schedules
by various European countries the
broadcasts were nothing more than a
female or male voice repeating a series
of numbers and letters the key feature
of these broadcasts is that the coded
messages they contained are completely
unbreakable and can only be understood
by the select few whom are supposed to
receive the messages despite many
attempts nobody apart from the intended
recipients has ever been able to decode
a numbers station message this is a
recording of a British number station
transmission
[Applause]
[Music]
and this is a German station known by
radio enthusiasts as the Swedish
Rhapsody it's uniquely features a really
creepy little girl there's a
particularly bizarre number station
called the backwards music station
because some believe it sounds like
music being played backwards the signal
is believed to be transmitted from both
the US and UK the difference between
this number station and most offers is
that it never plays any voice messages
just endless hellish noises
[Music]
[Applause]
one would think that number stations
would have died out at the end of the
Cold War around 1991 what they are still
widely used by intelligence agencies to
debt to transmit messages to spies
because shortwave radio still remains a
very reliable means of communication so
if you tuned in to the right frequency
at the right time you may be able to
hear a live broadcast of a real number
station if your image of space is a vast
silent nothingness dotted with
weird-looking rocks you would be half
wrong space is silent to the human ear
but with the right equipment you can
pick up and record vibrations in space
this is exactly what happened when
NASA's Voyager spacecraft recorded
Jupiter's atmosphere this is the sound
it picked up
[Music]
it's incredibly eerie to think that such
a sound can be made by a planet it
sounds more like an alien tractor beam
than a big ball of gas the sound is
actually a result of the complex
interactions are charged electromagnetic
particles and the planet solar winds and
magnetosphere Andy for playing an
instrument was complicated speaking of
space not all space noises come from
planets in 1977 the Big Ear radio
telescope at the Ohio State University
picked up a narrowband radio signal from
outer space that sounded like this
[Music]
it was named the WoW signal because the
man who first spotted it on the logs
circled it in red pen and wrote Wow
beside it but the peculiar thing about
the WoW signal is that it came from a
location in outer space that contains no
planets or galaxies a seemingly empty
area of space so how could a signal be
transmitted from an area of complete
nothingness unless it wasn't actually
empty many people believe the signal
came from an alien spacecraft traveling
through the vast emptiness of outer
space but to this day science still
can't explain where the signal
originated from thanks for the view
subscribe for more thoughty2
[Music]